>> Greg: NEPTUNE CITY.
THAT SOUNDS EXCITING.
ALL RIGHT, JESSE.
>> Jesse: MARCH MADNESS IS
HERE.
DANA, THAT IS COLLEGE
BASKETBALL.
>> Dana: SAYINGS.
>> Jesse: PIZZA HUT IS THE
OFFICIAL PIZZA OF MARCH MADNESS.
THEY CAME OUT WITH SOME SHOES.
PIZZA HUT HIGH TOPS.
YOU SEE THE RED, MARINARA
SPLASH.
THERE IS A CHEESE GRATER.
WHEN YOU PUSH THE BUTTON ON THE
TONGUE, IT ORDERS A PIZZA TO
WHEREVER YOU ARE.
IF YOU'RE WATCHING
MARCH MADNESS, YOU HIT THE
BUTTON ON THE TONGUE AND A PIZZA
GETS DELIVERED.
GO TO PizzaHut.com, DOWNLOAD
THE APP.
BLUETOOTH COMPATIBLE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
YOU HIT THE BUTTON AND YOU GET
THE PIZZA AND IF YOU HIT THE
OTHER BUTTON ON THE OTHER TONGUE
OF THE SHOE, IT PAUSES THE GAME
FOR YOU.
YOU CAN ENJOY YOUR PIZZA AND
FINISH WATCHING THE GAME.
>> Kimberly: I CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU DIDN'T PUT THEM ON.
>> Juan: HE DID.
>> Greg: WHERE IS THE PIZZA?
>> Juan: YOU PUSHED THE BUTTON
BUTTON?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: HERE IS THE SNEAKER.
>> Kimberly: YOU SHOULD REALLY
LEAVE THESE SEGMENTS TO ME.
>> Jesse: HERE WE GO.
>> Juan: OH, MY GOSH.
>> Jesse: THERE IT IS.
I JUST ORDERED IT.
GREG CAN'T HAVE ANY OF IT